who was better in bed
that is really hard because like Brad
was like the sort of major chemistry
love of your life kind of like at the
time you know
um
and then like Ben was like technically
excellent
[Laughter]
I'm back about sex with x's Brad Pitt
and Ben Affleck I can't believe my
daughter is listening to this
technically yeah excellent yeah on
caller daddy the actress spills all the
details about her past romances during a
game called Brad or Ben
it'll be fun okay
Brad no
Oh I thought that was the question Brad
or Ben who was more romantic
um Brad
it's really proud Brad
who was more likely to make you laugh
Ben Gwyneth dated Brad in the 90s after
meeting on the set of the 1995 film
seven
William I'd like you to meet David David
this is good all right I'm gonna I'll be
right back we sort of said hi on set and
it was like major major love at first
sight
it was crazy fast forward a year the two
got engaged yes I got engaged that's one
of the greatest moments of my life it's
just such a lovely time and we're having
so much fun with it all but Brad and
Gwyneth called it quits before ever
tying the knot I was totally heartbroken
when we broke up but it was just you
know the right thing at that time but it
was really it was really hard as for her
relationship with Ben the two starred in
a couple of films together including
balance you want to check it out it'll
just take a minute
sure they dated on and off from 1997 to
2000. so yeah there's a lot of history
there hence why host Alex Cooper asked
Gwyneth hard-hitting questions like who
is a better kisser
oh my God let me think gosh I have to
remember so far back they were both good
kissers okay a couple decades later and
gwyneth's only got high praise for her
former Flames she calls Brad such a good
person I really I love him I'm a big fan
the former couple even recently came
together as Brad launched a shirt line
called God's true cashmere he promoted
it with goop gwyneth's company when we
first broke up we weren't friends for a
while and then we sort of found our way
back
um probably about I don't know 18 or 19
years ago something like that and then
just kind of stayed in touch over the
years and I adore him he's an amazing
person and he's a great entrepreneur and
such a creative I mean you've got great
X's like you can't really go wrong you
know what I mean and those are just the
ones you know about
foreign